hello everybody hope they are good and I
really mean it because today the altcoin
market is getting wrecked
um I hope that some of you were prepared
because we've been talking about this
scenario for quite some time we've been
talking about this scenario for around a
month ago okay and now it's starting to
play out
so we are happy
and don't get me misunderstood of course
I'm sad for all those people but who
already had altcoins
and the portfolios are believing but I
know that some of you were getting ready
for this and were prepared for this and
that makes me happy okay so um you know
what is going on today I think is don't
get me wrong
I don't think this is the drop I'm gonna
go through the charts in a minute I
think that probably there is more upload
and it's not bad I like that a lot I'm a
vampire these drops okay this crosses
we're gonna see you know buy
opportunities
that is gonna make us a lot of money in
the next two years okay after the
Bitcoin Harvin next year would be I've
already talked about this book the
Halloween is going to be a spring in
2024 Bitcoin usually takes two months
two or three months to go up since then
so the most likely thing is that next
summer is when we're gonna start to see
the bull market is starting
we're gonna go in a minute through some
malt coins but let's check the Bitcoin
chart first
so this is the Bitcoin chart weekly time
frame and something that I've already
talked about is the crossover of the
20ma crossing above the fifth TMA in the
weekly time frame okay this is usually a
good time but I was telling you what you
want to see is a drop
and test this EMS support so you can
continue going higher okay that's what
you want to sit down the problem is that
with a desk drop and we are now below
the two EMAs
okay you can check in the top left
corner of the screen that's the levels
so the 20ma and the 50ma are pretty much
in the same Zone and that's around 25
850. and the thing is that tomorrow this
weekly Candlestick is going to close so
basically what you want to see for
Bitcoin is a close above that level okay
so let me Mark it for you that would be
this Zone above here and if we mark it
like this then you basically want to
close around this level okay do you want
to close at least about 25
865 by tomorrow otherwise price action
is going to tell us that most likely we
continue filling this liquidity pool
over here
and why not you know you have this week
over here let me do it yellow Wicks have
to be yellow liquidity that's the rule
of the channel guys
um that's a lot better so yeah basically
if we don't close the weekly Candlestick
tomorrow Above This level 25 865.
still lower prices you know fill this
liquidity pool fully and this week here
that is the 50 okay and that could take
us to 22k 20K why not I think that the
main thing to consider here is that
alcorns tend to bottom out a lot later
than Bitcoin okay and that means that
you know if this is supposedly your
Bitcoin bottom 15K all right I'm not
saying that it is uh of course you know
if you start to come lower here and
start to lose this level then you know
you have another liquid people here so
if you go lower than the week then you
know 16k is gonna happen again or 17K
um or why not even super delos so I'm
not saying this is your Bitcoin bottom
it looks like a bottom but the problem
is that all these imbalance is here on
the way uh it's not looking
that good okay but imagine this is your
Bitcoin bottom okay and now Bitcoin
drops here
you know this is this week here and then
it goes up bull market perfect okay then
in this drop here altcoins are gonna get
so wrecked okay because you're gonna
have the Bitcoin dominance is still high
I'm Bitcoin dropping so what you've seen
today you're gonna see that many more
days okay and at the end if you continue
having
ten percent drops ten percent drops 15
drops five percent drops you know alkins
are gonna get destroyed and these are
this is also something that I've been
saying before but I mean if you check
what happened in previous bear markets a
lot of all coins even most all coins
disappeared
why not now I mean if you check the
ranking of uh altcoins in market
capitalization so when I see that you
have pretty much the same altcoins as
one year ago
okay yes you've lost uh ftt you've lost
a Luna but to be honest it hasn't
changed that much has it that's also
what I'm telling you guys uh there could
be more pain on their way for altcoins
okay not saying I'm not even when I talk
about Bitcoin because I want to go level
by level so uh for now I'm looking only
for tomorrow's weekly Candlestick to
close if we close below 25 860.
[Music]
and then if we continue going lower then
you have this week at 20K okay if you go
below the week then you have the
security pool at 17K so we're gonna go
level by level because it's impossible
to know now if we are gonna go all the
way here or not all right
all that I can tell you is the
impossibles.net system Bitcoin okay when
you were at 31k
how many people said that it was
impossible to see a drop to 25k how many
there are no Impossibles in Bitcoin
anybody that tells you that it's
impossible to get there uh just don't
follow them because that's not true
everything is possible here okay so keep
a die in mind guys now I want to go
through some altcoins
let's go for example to uh let's go to
Ada all right Ada
the ones that I I made some videos
I think this is your chart
you may try to find it first
I see this one yes this is this one okay
so these are the liquidity pools Antares
to the applied for the Boar market okay
but what matters is here okay where
below our resistance here okay um we had
this straight line so it was a simple
lose this trend and we're gonna go a lot
lower okay this was our liquidity pool
here
so this one here it's a liquidity pool
a market like this LP right
if you guys are on your phones you're
not gonna see the lp there okay that's
your liquidy pool you can see that is
made an attempt
to go to the liquidity pool
at the moment were still above the
liquidity pool now I think the Ava is
probably sooner or later fall into this
liquid pool and this level here is 18
cents okay so we're talking about a drop
of
25 okay
um again I'm not telling you to wait and
buy here
first because it can even go lower but
also because you know I might be wrong
am I looking here but in my bounce so
again if you want to start DCA now
is the moment okay it wasn't before
when everybody was saying you maybe I
don't see soon maybe this is the bottom
we're gonna go to 40K no now is the time
because you can see the Bitcoin
dominance breaking out okay
so if you want to start this game I mean
you can't it's a valid idea I'm not
going to buy Aid at this level I can
tell you in advance because first I'm
not that interested in either although
in the previous bull market it is
something amazing but I mean if it goes
to this liquidity pool here then I'll
think about it and I'll also see how the
market is doing okay but that's pretty
much what I think about ADA now if we go
to Dot let's go to Pork a lot okay
um okay so if you go to polkadot
you can see here the today we made a new
lows okay
because if you notice
that's not sorry that's the previous one
that's two days low so you can see that
you know we've got lower than the
previous one so today made a new lows
this outcome now I think thoughts can go
even lower okay I think I shared a chart
of porkado some months ago in Twitter if
I'm not wrong but what I find
interesting about porkado is this Zone
over here
okay this one over here and that is
around
3.80 and 3.60 okay this is the song that
I find interesting okay I think if we or
even a fake out Aviation here
because if with the V8 here a 340 330
a lot of people are going to think that
Paul cadot is finished
all right and that's when you can see a
deviation and price can continue going
higher but you can see that you know
that making new lows and if you check
the
pole cut out on the Bitcoin pair
you can see that it's been bleeding for
ages okay and also we just broken below
this potential
support here okay this previous low so I
mean it's not looking great for altcoins
you can see Matic let's go formatic
quite dramatic
they can see that they feel this
liquidity pool
that I marked in my chart uh perfect
um to be honest we have here another
liquidity pool and I think that you know
I even said here I feel bison I think
it's likely that Matic goes to this Zone
sooner or later and that's between 27p
and 22p or cents sorry I think peace is
British and senses uh from the US well
okay since then so that's also quite you
know interesting of course it has a lot
more of room left to go down if you mark
from here down
I mean Marty can't take another 60 why
not go again to the total three
okay
is very simple
if you lose this level here they're
gonna fall into the liquidity pool and
that's a 30 drop also think that there
are some stable coins here so instead of
thirty percent might be uh 40 45 drop
for some altcoins now let's go to chain
link
and also most you are probably looking
at this chart
because uh if we check here
what we said that was going to happen
it's happening and I don't want to say
that I was right because I don't care
about the band just happy that I made
the right decision and that I gave you
the right info okay that's what I'm
happy about but you can see that you
know what we're inside this range that's
your high that's your low we were
waiting for some kind of deviation below
the range okay that would be something
like this to fill this liquidity pool
over here also to test this support here
you can see it's doing now so so let's
see I mean
chain link is quite interesting coin
because it's a coin that is been ranging
for one year so you can see the bear
Market
he's done pretty well I think
um now the question is
is this deviation
okay because I'll tell you this might be
navigation or maybe if waiting for a
bigger deviation okay and to be honest
if it deviates even more
which is possible that's another you
know maybe another 10 drop from the load
that we established today all right
um
that's quite interesting again if it's
your first bison
feel free to buy link I think it's uh I
don't think it's a battery level 2i I'll
be honest with you because uh geography
are very strong support you know I've
been reading for quite some time we have
this Equity pool has been filled if it
drops lower
then you know you might have other
levels here for example
this level over here let me take it here
okay that's
3.34 could drop that low I mean that
would be quite a big deviation wouldn't
it not sure if it can go that low uh how
much drop is this
thirty percent off on chain link is
quality I mean could do it but again the
same you can if you want to start buying
here and then have some bti if you lose
the support or if you want to play it
safe and you're gonna play the deviation
in a safer way you know you can't wait
to recover this range here at this level
which is isn't that far away you're not
going to lose my Precision in price that
is at 5 30. okay so if you want what you
can do is wait to see if this navigation
and once you are back inside the range
and test your support then you come back
again here and for example Target the
middle of range 740 and then on top of
range all right why not uh that's what I
think about the chain link at the moment
pretty happy that I play it out uh so
far
as we said on fill the liquidity pool
and test our support
but of course not saying that I can go
lower now let's think about more
altcoins
um
Solana let's go to Solana let's check
Solana
Solana usdt sorry I'm done with no what
I'm doing here
that's better okay uh I don't think I
think I have a chart already for oh
there it is
that one there okay
okay let me check What's Happening Here
okay uh you can see that we
lost this support
then we were Target in the week this
week has been filled and the problem now
is that you still have this liquidity
pool
all the way here okay and that will take
you to
around ten dollars I'll probably say the
the levels that I would Mark in my chart
are you know this Equity pool here ten
dollars I think again this would be uh I
I assume that it would be fine to buy
here okay because that would be how much
of a drop
30 drop why not okay again this is not
for Traders this is a video mainly for
holders and investors because if you go
into the one hour time frame of course
you're gonna see that the chat is
looking quiver extended although you
have this week here okay so why not you
might even come again to this level and
then have a bounce right and then
continue going lower uh but again this
video is more for holders so this if you
want to do a buy you know you can try to
buy again in this Zone bro I think
eventually Maybe
in Solomons he can go right below ten
dollars so that's what I think about
Solana guys I think I pretty much
covered the main all twins in this video
at least the ones that I've been talking
about for quite some time
let's go back to the total three so let
me wrap this up guys uh I think that you
know all queens are making new lows
remember that the total three chart is
uh alcohol and stable coins so you know
the stable Queens are stable they're
flat so they are you know keeping this
chart a bit higher than it is for
articles if you have a chart only for
altcoins I don't if they exist then I
can tell you that this red candle would
be below this lows okay it will already
be in this one here all right because if
you check all levels they are pretty
much most of them making new lows okay
so
um that's what I think I think also that
this just might be one leg down you know
we might see a bounce but I think
eventually the market looks like he
might want to fill the security pool
here and that will tell you that
the damage is not finished okay there
will be a lot more blood and if we have
a look at the Bitcoin dominance chart
and my opinion is the most important
chart at the moment and the one that
helped us to predict this move all right
so if you check uh way heartbreaking
Above This resistance and the idea now
is that if we can hold
this previous resistance support okay if
we can do something like this now and
holding this Zone
then alkins are going to continue
getting lower but now imagine if then
after this we can see a bounce you know
go towards 52 percent uh in my opinion
you might think it's a big Target but if
you zoom out
you know what are the lows look how high
it can go all right uh budget I think
even if it goes to 50 to 52 percent
alcohol could get destroyed okay and
they might drop another 20 from here
that's what I think guys uh so please be
very careful uh I would ask you to
I would recommend you to you know uh
this weekend
relax you know go through the charts
this video shouldn't determine what you
are gonna do next is just my personal
opinion so this we can go through the
charts try to find the Bisons of your
favorite alphones that you like and then
just set some order status levels okay
so you know take the weekend for that
don't try to go now and trade because
now it might go sideways until tomorrow
um you know I recommend you to to go
through some altcoins and throw your buy
zones okay so that's pretty much
everything guys I hope that you enjoyed
the video uh today I was gonna take the
day off if I'm honest with you but I saw
what happened today in the altcoin
market and I asked you on Twitter should
I make a video or not
and geez I don't know how many of you
have notifications some but that was
crazy I've got so many notifications you
explode my phone so thank you guys
Jason